hello hello hello let's get into this I
think I have a lot to say then again I
don't know welcome to this Q&A video I
went on my Instagram story and I asked
you guys for questions that I could
answer you could ask me breast cancer
related questions you could ask me non-
breast cancer related questions whatever
you want and wow did you offer quite a
spectrum of questions thank you for that
I do feel like maybe I should have
prepared my answers for this but we're
just going to go with what comes up in
this moment it's kind of an overarching
lesson that I've been sort of forced to
learn over the last four or five months
but an incredibly valuable lesson
nonetheless we're going with the flow
look how effortless and natural it is
for us to go with the flow we don't have
control issues or a desperate need for
certainty at all we are easy breezy
Cover Girl more like easy breezy hiding
under the covers girl let's let's get
into it I had a double messed ectomy
this week and went flat due to
recurrence what is your plan wow kudos
to you for going through such an intense
surgery and I hope your recovery goes
well the fact that you're on your phone
and responding to my Instagram story I
assume you're doing pretty okay here's
the plan I'm doing a lumpectomy
lumpectomy lumpectomy is that the right
that's the right word right is that I'm
not hi lump back to me yeah but that
didn't sound right to me o this is going
to be quite a curious time is it I'm
having a lumpectomy done next week but
at the same time that I'm getting my
lumpectomy done my doctor is getting
surgical samples of those ooh curious
calcium deposits that showed up from
what I understand they don't look too
concerning but she wants to get a bigger
sample than what was gotten from the
biopsy just to be sure and I love just
being sure a little over a week after
surgery we will find out if I've had a
pathological SE R I believe that's the
phrase CR meaning complete response I'm
going to have a week over Christmas
that's going to
be weird it'll be fine it'll be fine
it'll be fine I love uncertainty how has
treatment affected your self-image well
I can't say that it hasn't affected my
self-image I have definitely struggled
through this process as I'm sure
everyone that goes through this process
has struggled with their self-image with
just feeling beautiful it really
confronts you with the ways in which you
might not even realize you feel
beautiful whether that's your hair
feeling at home in your own body or safe
in your own skin ecosystem I've
definitely had moments where I feel very
very insecure about the way I look
through this process and I've been able
to kind of meet those feelings I think
in a much healthier way than I ever
could or did when I was younger the kind
of cool thing is that it's helped me
like relinquish control control that
said do I feel a healthy surrender of
control all the time no and to be honest
I'm not totally sure what you mean by
self image I'm sort of interpreting it
about the way that I like see myself on
an aesthetic or physical level and it's
been kind of nice to be confronted with
a lot of like lingering ghosts in my
closet from eating disorder past about
body image and to be able to meet and
see and try to understand those feelings
which I could never ever do before my
relationship with my self-image is
evolving it is up and down some days I
feel okay some days I don't and both of
those are okay you know it's easy to say
that it's a lot of work behind the
scenes to to be with all those feelings
it's weird everything about this is
weird when I had chemo it totally
changed my taste buds did you have this
if so what change what Chang PF Chang
sounds great right now but I wouldn't be
able to taste it the way I used used to
taste it because yes my taste buds have
changed have changed I have a metallic
taste in my mouth which I was privy to
would happen I sort of knew my taste
buds were changing but it didn't really
really hit me until I got this orzo
salad from Gelson's the grocery store
that I love so much and when it showed
up I ate it and it did not taste like
how I remember it confirmed that my
mouth is different my mouth got
different but I've also heard that you
should avoid the foods that you love the
most during this process because you
will after this process associate with
this process and no longer love those
Foods so as much as I want all of my
favorite things mostly like I just want
like cold leftovers like cold noodles
like cold lowain or cold fried rice one
of my favorite food groups is cold
leftovers I don't want to have them
right now because I know that they won't
taste the way that I remember them which
is so disgusting and com com forting and
I don't want to ruin that Association so
we'll get there yes taste buds have
changed mouth got different did the cold
cap work it looks like it did just know
it varies for everyone okay I did want
to talk about the cold capping
experience cold capping is a service
that you can pay for that you can try it
is not guaranteed that it will work I
got a lot of great information from a
friend that went through this process
there's different services for cold
capping there's one called penguin I use
one called digy caps I believe there
might even be more but those are the two
kind of in Los Angeles and they vary on
where they're available the digy Caps
cost
$450 every session that you do it they
have insurance forms on their website
where you can file an insurance claim to
see if your insurance will cover it
which is currently the process that I'm
in I kind of always went into this
thinking that this is a gamble it's not
guaranteed maybe it'll work maybe it
won't work I had a really great
experience truly didn't lose that much
hair considering however this last week
I have lost more hair than I have this
entire process and they tell you that
hair shedding can happen up to two
months after your last chemo session I
know it looks okay I think what really
saved me is that I had incredibly thick
hair going into this and I'm not totally
sure and I'm a little concerned and I
guess maybe this ties into the
self-image question with how much it
will continue to shed in this capacity
wouldn't it be funny if I had to shave
my head
at the very end of all of this I got
warned on the discomfort of it it was
very uncomfortable I put this cold cap
on and they wet your hair down and it
essentially freezes your entire scalp so
that the hair follicles aren't exposed
to the chemo drugs that go into your
system and like the first half hour I
was told it was the worst brain freeze
of your life so I was truly prepared for
it to be incredibly painful and I think
because I gave myself incredibly high
expectations of the pain threshold it
wasn't too bad however there's a lot of
adrenaline going into to infusion days
you're pump full of steroids so I think
I had a lot of assistance um with
handling the discomfort by the sixth
round I was definitely ready for that
experience to be over maybe I should
just I'm just going to show you so my
hair is very flat this it looks pretty
good right but you can see there's a lot
of balding there's a lot of you know
hair's going hair's gone and that will
be Cur ious for it to grow back but
overall like pretty okay so at least at
this moment I've had a pretty great
experience with cold capping pretty
successful but I would look into it for
yourself and see if it's worth it my dad
is starting chemo soon what's something
you would like to have had since round
one ooh okay one of the things that was
a little overwhelming for me was kind of
the organization of everything there's a
lot to manage you're given a lot of
medications to have on hand at home for
potential side effects in the very
beginning I kept a symptom Journal
marking off how I was feeling every day
and when I took my medication because I
would very quickly forget how long ago I
took this nausea pill and can I take it
again right now developing a system of
organization with all of the medications
and with all of the other things that
you might need I also as this process
went on got a little duller and foggier
in my brain and so my system tended to
break down a little bit so if you're
able to be there for your dad when maybe
he doesn't have the sharpest cognition
going that would be super helpful what
else since round one cozy socks these oh
God it's all of my hair these have been
like a true amazing creature Comfort I
think this came in the bag that The
Volunteers at the infusion center gave
me my very first round and I was like oh
they're just giving me like a bunch of
stuff that I don't know if I need but
I'll politely accept because they're the
sweetest most beautiful women I've ever
experienced that have also survived
their own breast cancer Journeys and are
giving back in a tremendous way and then
these socks ended up being something
I've worn almost like every day or every
few days cozy socks easy to throw on
that's an amazing thing to have from the
beginning have you ever pulled the
cancer card to get out of something you
don't want to do no I haven't done it
yet but I kind of look forward to doing
it in the future at what point did you
start feeling like a grown-up I'm 36 and
I still be like I need an adult oh I
don't feel like a grown-up what does
being a grown-up feel like I don't know
what does it feel like it must not feel
like you have your together what
makes you feel like a grownup paying
taxes I do that so technically on paper
I guess I'm a grown up I feel like an
impostor in my age bracket I see
wrinkles showing up and I see gray hairs
growing in nature is telling me that I'm
getting older I don't know if mentally I
have taken that on I don't know I don't
know did our parents ever feel like
grown-ups maybe it's just that we have
this awareness because we have access to
the internet and everyone talks about
this all the time we all feel younger
than we actually are and we all have
impostor syndrome and we all have
anxiety and we all feel disconnected and
that feels weird because we're like you
shouldn't be feeling this way but maybe
everyone's always felt this way since
the beginning of time they just didn't
have an invisible system in which they
could communicate with each other across
long distances and connect on the
feelings that made them feel isolated is
that thought process adult I don't know
what is something that has had an
unexpected profound effect on you I mean
the just the care and the reaching out
of support it is overwhelming the
messages that I get in my DMs of people
going through similar experiences or
experiencing a family member going
through a similar experience they're
just so heartfelt and it is just such a
real connection that you have really
does make it feel like you get pushed
into this community that is beautiful
and also so complex because everyone's
dealt with so much in different and
similar ways and you feel very connected
and bonded on I guess the trauma of it
and it feels like I've entered this
other community or this other world that
I guess I've existed parallel to but
have never experienced directly the
kindness and the tenderness in which
people have connected with me and wanted
to help has just surged this part of me
that wants to give back and I'm not
entirely sure exactly
how I want to do that yet but I just
want to pay it forward that's had a
really profound resonant effect that I
think will be lasting which part of
cancer was harder the physical symptoms
part or the mental health anxiety they
were equally difficult in different ways
obviously a lot of confronting of a lot
of things the physical side effects and
then to take action to take the
medications or to do the things that
would make you feel better I didn't
realize how much my tendency to
suffer was it is so embedded in me
consciously and unconsciously to just
sort of suffer through like pain and
then I'd remember that I have nausea
medication that that's what I should be
taking for this feeling rather than just
sitting in this really uncomfortable
feeling and then there's a lot of days
where you just like feel bad I'm really
thankful that I had done a lot of work
in therapy and that I continued to talk
to my therapist twice a week was really
valuable in helping me process my
feelings and to say things out loud and
to journal you know if you can't do
therapy just Journal just put what the
goofy goofy things happening up here out
on paper there is something about
transferring them that takes a lot of
the weight out of it they sit up here
like sandbags they just like weigh on
you these thoughts these anxiety beliefs
and Loops I have so many Loops of
anxiety thoughts be able to start
putting them out on paper get the
sandbags out of my head and and stop the
loops I like forget to journal still and
I have to remind myself to do it like
exercise like it sometimes feels a
little tedious and I don't feel like
doing it and then I do it and I feel
better and I go see and then I'm like
you brat and I'm like no we got to be
friends with
ourselves and just like okay fine let's
just eat some
snacks that's mental health did you use
weed during chemo and if so did it help
out in any way oh yes it did I smoked a
lot of joints throughout this because I
love to drink weed they make weed
beverages out here in Los Angeles what a
treat and then they started to upset my
stomach Edibles for some reason also
were a little wonky for me so I started
smoking joints and that really helped
especially on days that I felt a lot of
physical pain helped me have an appetite
it also helped me get out of the anxiety
a little bit there were other times
however that it made my stomach feel
worse or it made me paranoid and
hyperfixated on the the pains that I was
experiencing in my body and so it really
was a balance but it doesn't work for
everyone so find what works for you has
Goose acted differently towards you
since your diagnosis think she knows I
think she knows something on my worst
days on the couch she would lay next to
me and it would make me want to cry and
then she would see me crying and be like
oh my God what's wrong and I'd be like
no these are good tears you're doing the
best job and she be like I know I'm
doing the best I can I misunderstood
emotionally and I was like that's why
can I get you dog literal dog and then
Elliot would come in I'd be like I just
smoked a joint and goose and I are
having a great conversation in my head
could you leave us alone please oops my
camera just died because the internal
temperature got too hot and I'm like
same girl you getting a hot flesh too
was getting your brows done worth it
absolutely yes regardless of the chemo
it has been so fun to have these
eyebrows which I cannot wait to get
touched up when this is over talk about
the balance between your privacy and
also sharing your chemo cancer Journey
that's interesting sometimes you just
feel very compelled to do something and
it's almost impossible not to act on it
and I have had the thoughts of wow what
if you kept this whole thing a secret
but I think a lot of my coping mechanism
with difficult things in the past has
been trying to keep it a secret and that
ultimately for me at least is so much
more effort than putting it out there
and because this is such a
complex experience and also something
that so many people go through it felt
really valuable to me to be able to
connect with other people and to hear
about other people's experiences by
means of exposing my own and to feel
less alone because this whole thing
feels very isolating it also has felt
easy to share because it's just the most
honest thing going on with me and I
don't feel like I'm trying to curate a
package of my life in a way that makes
me like look good to an audience it
feels like less work even this is
literally what I'm going through and
this is literally how I think about it
at the same time I do still value my
privacy and haven't shown the worst
parts of it I still value keeping some
of the extremely personal things to
myself for me as a Libra that's looking
for balance is the way that I find
balance the feedback of feeling like
this connects for a lot of people has
been just like very inspiring to me to
feel like there's a purpose I think a
lot of the frivolous not frivolous the
absolutely amazing internet content that
I've made in the past sort of boiled to
a head in my most burnt out chapter
where it just felt like what the who
cares that was my own sort of beating
myself up and losing sense of like what
I creatively felt called to do and this
has just reignited like a deeper purpose
of being able to share this what's the
most Libra thing about you I don't know
that I'm wildly indecisive absolutely
wildly chaotically inde
decisive and oh so Charming it's tough
to trust the medical system how why did
you feel confident in your treatment
plan thankfully I had a friend that I
truly trusted that had gone through this
same diagnosis four years prior and she
gave me a lot of confidence in the
treatment plan triple positive breast
cancer has a pretty straightforward
treatment plan that works so there
wasn't a lot of second guessing by any
of my doctors and there wasn't a lot of
here's plan b or c so that ultimately
just made me feel confident that they
were like here it is this is what you're
doing and I was like great I don't have
to consider anything else in this
already emotionally overwhelming
experience I love that for me but I know
that's not the case for everyone I also
just inherently feel stupid as a human
being existing in the world so when I
encounter a doctor I just put Authority
on them immediately and I inherently
trust them that might be a little bit of
a character flaw that I'm a bit too
trusting I don't know but in this
situation it worked out for me that said
I have also learned in this process that
you need to speak up for yourself before
I got officially diagnosed with cedi I
was having a really hard time I was
borderline unconscious for like 2 days
straight without realizing it because I
didn't have a heart rate monitor which
they sell on Amazon is a great thing to
buy if you're going through this
experience wrist monitors that measure
your heart rate they're cheap have them
on hand if ever you're experiencing
extreme fatigue to make sure that you're
still well within conscious levels cuz I
was literally in unconscious levels and
in that experience Elliot and I quickly
learned how important it is to be
extremely upfront with your doctor about
the symptoms that you're experiencing
and not just chalk it up to maybe you'll
feel better in the morning it was
incredibly important that we got to the
hospital when we did so lesson learned
probably the hard way I do trust my
doctors but I also have to be very
upfront with I'm feeling bad sir what
should I do okay there's still a ton of
questions that I have maybe I'll do a
part two of this down the line but my
camera is done
I have recorded for probably an hour
because I've been so rambly at this
point so I'm going to wrap it up and
maybe I'll do a part two of Q&A with the
questions that are left over cuz you
guys asked so many great ones thank you
so much for these questions I hope these
answers were helpful they were
definitely long- winded which is a
testament to the fact that I have some
stamina now that I can quack at this
camera for an hour straight and still
feel like I can go on this camera simply
can't I'm outlasting technology on a
physical level perhaps this what doesn't
kill you makes you stronger thing is
working out for all hellig okay before I
dive too deep into the fantasy of me
having physical authority over machines
I think I should get going thank you so
much for watching I will see you the
next time I turn this camera on um other
than that I don't know it's fun to say
that at the end of videos now it feels
comforting in a way because it's true I
have no Fu clue what's going on ever